guten
Morgen den her ich begrüße Sie herzlich
zur Pressekonferenz mit
verteigister vielen Dank seh
frekär sehrte Damen und Herren Medien
zunächst zu Beginn eines Jahres darf ich
Ihnen allen ein neues gutes neues Jahr
wünschen viel Glück und
Gesundheit wünschen jeder Jahreswechsel
bitte doch immer wieder die Möglichkeit
Bilanz zu ziehen Bilanz über das
vergangene Jahr auch zu ziehen und genau
das möchten wir heute gemeinsam tun für
den Grundwehrdienst und für den
Zivildienst so jeder junge Mann kennt
sie die stellungsstraßen und unseres
Bundesheeres im Jahr
2023 wurden gesamt
Wehrpflichtige in den stellungsstraßen
in Österreich untersucht das bedeutet
eine geringfügige Änderung zum Jahr
2022 indem es
45782 junge Männer waren von diesen
genannten
waren
31516 diensttauglich auch hier die
Vergleichszahl dazu aus dem Jahr
2022 da waren es
639 waren teiltaglich im Jahr davor also
im Jahr 2022 waren es
758 das heißt
99889 waren Dienst untauglich im Jahr
davor
9918 und 34 421 waren vorübergehend
Dienst untauglich im Jahr
2023 und im Jahr
2022 waren es
3062 was heißt dieses vorübergehend
Dienst untauglich das bedeutet dass
diese junge Männer zu einem späteren
Zeitpunkt nochmals zur Stellung gebeten
werden und sich dann noch entscheiden
können ob sie den Grundwehrdienst oder
den Zivildienst antreten möchten ich
möchte an dieser Stelle insbesondere zum
Aspekt der
teiltauglichkeit einige Worte finden
weil das ja auch in den vergangenen
Tagen immer wieder Thema war auch medial
Thema war für mich für uns ist eines
ganz klar mit dieser teiltaglichkeit die
wir neu eingeführt haben geben wir
vielen jungen Menschen die Möglichkeit
ihren Dienst für die Gesellschaft zu
leisten und gerade hier sei es beim
Bundesheer oder
auch in den Einrichtungen die
Zivildiener beschäftigen ist jede jede
helfende Hand mehr ein Gewinn für uns am
Ende des Tages aber auch für die gesamte
Gesellschaft eines ist auch klar so wie
in vielen Bereichen meines Ressorts
evaluieren wir ständig und arbeiten
immer wieder auch an
Verbesserungen sehr gerne Damen und
Herren was wir bereits bei diesen
genannten Zahlen sehen ist dass die
Anzahl der werrpflichtigen zurückgeht
das ist insbesondere auf die geburtens
Schwachen Jahrgänge auch zurück
zuuführen und was wir auch sehen ist
dass von dieser geringeren Anzahl der
werrpflichtigen immer mehr untauglich
sind und wenn ich davon spreche dann
denke ich muss es in unser aller
Interesse sein als Gesellschaft dafür
Sorge zu tragen dass die junge
Generation wieder fitter und wieder
gesünder wird nicht nur deshalb damit
wir äh mehr an grundwehr Dienern und
Zivildienern zur Verfügung haben sondern
um Aufgaben zum Schutz der Sicherheit
und zur Versorgung auch erfüllen zu
können das ist im Sinne der allgemeinen
Gesundheit unsere stellungsstraßen in
ganz Österreich unsere sechs
stellungsstraßen die Leisten hier einen
wertvollen Dienst weil auf der einen
Seite und das kommt leider immer wieder
vor oder zum Glück immer wieder vor
werden hier
unentdeckte zuvor unentdeckte
Krankheiten erkannt damit oft die
Gesundheit verbessert oder eben sogar
Leben gerettet auf der anderen Seite
nutzen wir diese Möglichkeit auch um
Tipps und Ratschläge zu geben zur
Verbesserung der Gesundheit glaub man
kann daher tatsächlich von unseren
stellungsstraßen
als den gesundheitsstraßen der gesamten
Nation auch sprechen wir bauen diese
laufend aus einige von ihnen waren ja
auch dabei als wir im Dezember die neue
stellungsstraße im heresspital in Wien
übergeben haben
das war im übrigen der erste Bau auf
einer militärischen Liegenschaft nach
einem ganzen Jahrzehnt den wir übergeben
haben wir bauen zur Zeit auch das heres
Spital in Tirol aus wir beginnen damit
und zu modernisieren sind eigentlich
dann nur mehr zwei stellungsstraßen das
heißt der Steiermark und kernten um die
wir noch kümmern müssen wenn wir zu den
Grundwerten kommen die im Jahr 2023
ihren Dienst im Bundesheer
angetreten haben dann waren es
15544 in
gesamtösterreich sie haben glaube ich in
Ihren Unterlagen eine genaue
Aufschlüsselung auch noch oder werden
sie noch erhalten mit der
Medieninformation wo man auch die
Aufteilung nach den Bundesländern sieht
für unsere grundwerdiener arbeiten wir
als Bundesheer tagtäglich daran dass wir
Ihre Zeit beim herer verbessern das
heißt dafür sorgen dass diese wirklich
als erfüllende auch wahrgenommen wird
und es ist uns gemeinsam tatsächlich
einiges gelungen über ein ganzes
Jahrzehnt äh ist das soll für die
Grundwerten und damit auch für die
Zivildiener nicht erhöht worden
mittlerweile ist es uns gelungen dass
wir diesen um rund 50% erhöhen wenn ich
von den grundwertinen spreche dann waren
das 362 € die erhöht haben auf
536 € jetzt kommt dann noch einmal ab
dem jän ab
1..224 etwas dazu dass wir bei den
grundwerinen bei
585 € sind und neben dem finanziellen
Aspekt arbeiten wir auch daran dass wir
die
Rahmenbedingungen für die grundwertier
verbessern das ist zum einermal die
Infrastruktur über die ich schon
gesprochen habe die wir modernisieren
das sind auch die
Unterkunftsgebäude die wir auf
Vordermann bringen damit eben auch die
Lebensqualität für die Soldatinnen und
Soldaten gesteigert wird ich darf da
erinnern und sie sind ja immer wieder
bei diesen Terminen auch mit dabei dass
wir die wahnschaftsgebäude in allensteig
in Innsbruck in der steiermarkt da
könnte ich jetzt noch lange sprechen
bereits übergeben haben ein großes
Bauprogramm dass wir eben nach und nach
durchziehen äh unsere grundwerdeder
profitieren aber auch von weiteren gut
ist wie z.B eben dem klimaticket äh oder
auch der Wohnkosten Beihilfe und vielen
weiteren Unterstützungen das heißt
bessere Entlohnung ist uns gelungen
Unterbringung da konnten wir tatsächlich
sehr viele neue Projekte auch umsetzen
und starten und eines meiner Herzens
Anliegen aber ich glaube das ist ihen
auch bekannt sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren das ist der freiwillige
Grundwehrdienst für Frauen den wir mit 1
April des vergangenen Jahres eingeführt
haben eine Maßnahme nach 25 Jahren das
war der 1 April damals im Jahr 1998 als
die ersten Frauen beim Bund Desh
eingerückt sind haben wir erstmalig mit
dem letzten Jahr die einstiegskriterien
in das her gleich gemacht auch für
die Frauen das heißt wir geben den
Frauen so wie den Männern die
Möglichkeit sich des Bundesheer ein
halbes Jahr anzuschauen und dann
hoffentlich festzustellen dass wir ein
attraktiver Dienstgeber auch sind mit
dieser neuen Maßnahme haben wir nicht
gewusst wie sie angenommen wird äh jetzt
können wir sagen es ist tatsächlich ein
großer Erfolg geworden und ich hoffe das
wird auch weiterhin so bleiben weil seit
dem startat haben sich bereits über 200
Frauen freiwillig gemeldet es haben
davon bereits 149 die Eignungsprüfung
abgelegt und von diesen sind bereits 126
eingerückt oder haben eben schon ihren
Einberufungsbefehl in den Händen glaub
man kann tatsächlich daavon einem
meinenstein der Gleichberechtigung
zwischen Mann und Frau im Bundesheer
sprechen und es sag das ist auch ein
ganz ganz wichtiger Schritt äh für für
unsere gesamte Gesellschaft m ein ein
Schlagwort das war glaube ich in jedem
Bereich und zwar bei uns beim Bundesheer
denke wird bei euch auch nicht anders
sein finde das ist der Bürokratie Abbau
aber das ist bei uns nicht nur ein
Schlagwort das sons wirklich einiges
gelungen mit der Einführung vom
Bundesheer online können whrpflichtige
aber auch Milizsoldaten jetzt Ihre
Stammdaten eingeben kontrollieren auch
ändern und damit
sozialversicherungsrechtliche Anliegen
wie z.B die angesprochene
wohnkostenhilfe Beihilfe oder auch den
Familienunterhalt selber sozusagen
einarbeiten ich glaub das ist ein
Angebot das auch gut angenommen worden
ist gestartet jetzt Ende Juni 2023 und
das haben bereits
13500 Personen auch angenommen aber auch
da müssen wir weiter arbeiten an
Verbesserungen der Plan ist dass wir
dann mit spätestens Anfang Februar die
Möglichkeit auch den Zivildienern beten
dass sie den
Familienunterhalt oder auch die
wohnkostenbeihilfe über dieses Tool über
Bundesheer online auch beantragen können
sehr Gere Damen und Herren zum Schluss
ist es mir wirklich ein Bedürfnis mich
zu bedanken bei den vielen grundwertinen
aber auch den zivildenern und
insbesondere ihren Ausbildern denn die
leisten einen unglaublich wichtigen
unschätzbaren Dienst für die gesamte
Gesellschaft und das tun sie rund um die
Uhr ich bitte aber auch all diejenigen
die uns heute hier zuschauen dass Sie
diese Chance auch nutzen die richtige
Entscheidung auch zu treffen sie
bekommen bei uns eine Ausbildung eine
besondere Ausbildung die sie durchaus
auch in ihrem späteren Leben brauchen
können sei es wenn es um die Frage des
Führerscheines geht oder auch um die
Sanitäts Ausbildung geht und nutzen Sie
auch die Möglichkeit zu entdecken welche
Berufsfelder Ihnen das österreichische
Bundesheer anbieten kann nicht nur den
Beruf der Soldatin oder des Soldaten
oder auch einen im Gesundheits und
Pflegebereich dieser Lebensabschnitt ist
ein ganz besonderer der auch geprägt ist
von Zusammenhalt und von Kameradschaft
quer durch alle Gesellschaftsschichten
hinweg sie schließen Freundschaften die
manchmal ein ganzes Leben lang andoren
und daher an dieser Stelle eine bitte
sehen Sie diesen Dienst für Österreich
als eine Chance als eine Chance für ihr
gesamtes Leben ich danke vielmals und
würde jetzt meine Kollegin Frau
Staatssekretärin kaudia blackholm bitten
eine Bilanz über den Zivildienst zu
ziehen vielen Dank geschätzte Frau
Bundesministerin liebe Claudia Liebe
medienvertreterinnen Liebe
Medienvertreter heute ist wieder so ein
Tag der Zahlenkolonnen deswegen auch gut
dass sie in der Medieninformation vieles
auch nachlesen können auch für die
Bundesländer aufbereitet ist sie kennen
ja das bereits in diesem Rahmen und ich
freue mich sehr dass in meiner
Zuständigkeit explizit für den
Zivildienst bereits zum vierten Mal eine
anz ziehen darf in den letzten Monaten
bei der letzten Pressekonferenz zur
Quartalsbilanz habe ich bereits
ankündigen dürfen die Prognose dass es
voraussichtlich 2023 mehr Zivildiener
gibt als im Vorjahr diese Prognose hat
sich auch gehalten wir hatten im
vergangenen Jahr
31516 taugliche junge Männer und davon
haben
16871 Burschen eine Zivildiensterklärung
abgegeben 14600 30 wurden bisher einer
von
15501 zivilensteinrichtungen zugewiesen
das sind insgesamt sehr sehr stolze
Zahlen gerade wenn man auch ein bisschen
in der Geschichte zurückblickt in den
70er Jahren genau 1975 hat man die
Zivildiener noch an einer Hand quasi
abzählen können 344 waren es in gesamt
Österreich zu Beginn um genau zu sein 92
waren es dann bereits
8200 und im Jahr
199393 ist die Zahl dann auf 13900 junge
Männer angestiegen die den Staatsdienst
im Sozialbereich ableisten aber kommen
wir zum Jahr
2023 zurück die zivildiensteinrichtungen
haben im vergangenen Jahr einen Bedarf
von
16309 zivildenern eingemeldet dem
gegenüber stehen die
14630 Zuweisungen und das ergibt in
Summe eine Bedarfsdeckung von
89,7% der Vergleich zum Vorjahr 22 dort
lag die Bedarfsdeckung bei
87,8% also wir haben die in diesem einen
Jahr umfasst 2% steigern können das
Rettungswesen ist mit 40% nach wie vor
und mit Abstand der größte und
beliebteste Einsatzort der Zivildiener
gefolgt von
26% in der sozial und Behindertenhilfe
11% in der alten Betreuung und
vielleicht da nur ein bisschen zu den
bundesländerzahlen des Bundesländer
Ranking mit den meisten Zuweisungen
fürührt Wien mit
22,4% an gefolgt von Oberösterreich mit
20,1% und Niederösterreich mit 16,3% das
Feldt von hinten rollen Kärnten und
Burgenland mit 4,2 bzw 3% dann auf für m
persönlich ist der Zivildienst immer
auch der Headhunter für den
Sozialbereich denn bis zu 70% der jungen
Burschen die neun Monate ihren
Zivildienst leisten bleiben auch nach
diesen neun Monaten entweder ha amtlich
oder auch ehrenamtlich ihren
Einrichtungen erhalten und ich finde das
kann man nicht oft genug betonen weil es
auch sehr sehr viel über den Zivildienst
über die Einrichtungen über die
Zivildiener selbst aussagt zum ersten
zeigt es dass unsere
zivildiensteinrichtungen 15501 an der
Zahl hervorragende Arbeit leisten weil
sie schaffen es in wenigen Monaten nicht
nur einen Einblick zu geben sondern auch
junge Burschen für die Arbeit mit
Menschen zu begeistern vielen herzlichen
Dank DAF für diese engagierte Arbeit
nicht nur in der Ausbildung aus meiner
Sicht ist es nämlich auch notwendig dass
wir mehr Burschen genau in diese
Zielgruppe bringen in diese
Berufsbereiche auch bringen wir brauchen
nicht nur mehr Mädels in der Technik
sondern wir brauchen umgekehrt im Sinne
der Gleichberechtigung auch mehr
Burschen in der Pflege in der Gesundheit
im Sozialbereich um auch dort ein
halbwegs ausgewogenes Geschlechter
Verhältnis irgendwann zu erreichen und
zum zweiten zeigt es einmal mehr dass
junge Burschen oftmals nur eine
Berührungspunkt brauchen um irgendwie
auf den Geschmack zu kommen ich bin
jedes Jahr aufs Neue tief gerührt von
den unglaublichen Geschichten der
Zivildiener des Jahres die wir
Auszeichnung auszeichnen Begegnungen mit
alten Menschen mit Kindern mit ja
Menschen die auf Hilfe angewiesen sind
Menschen mit Beeinträchtigungen und da
wird der Staatsdienst für unglaublich
viele von der ungeliebten Pflicht zum
Türöffner in Richtung weiterer
beruflicher Laufbahn möglicherweise auch
in ein eine ganz unerwartete Richtung
die man eben dann noch abgeschlossener
Pflichtschule abgeschlossener Matura
oder Lehre dann einschlägt egal ob beim
bundesher oder beim Zivildienst der
Zivildienst bedeutet neun Monate für die
Gemeinschaft für Menschen die es am
notwendigsten brauchen herzugeben für
unser Land auch herzugeben und als
zuständige Staatssekretärin möchte ich
auch weiterhin alles daran setzen dass
wir logische Anknüpfungspunkte in das
zivile Leben finden wo diese Burschen
dann eben auch
ja den statsdienst nutzbar machen können
einen dieser logischen Anknüpfungspunkte
haben wir mit der Grundausbildung Pflege
geschaffen weil damit der Zivildienst
die neu Monate Zivildienst auch auf
pflegeausbildungen anrechenbar geworden
sind hier werden wir auch weiter dran
bleiben nicht nur in der Praxis
praktischen Umsetzung ein riesengroßes
Dankeschön nicht nur den Zivildienern in
unserem Land sondern insbesondere auch
den grundwerttienern in Österreich jeder
einzelne leistet einen unglaublichen
Beitrag zur Solidarität in unserem Land
wir brauchen euch unbedingt insbesondere
auch die grundwertdiener Österreich ist
ein neutrales Land aber die Neutralität
alleine die wird uns nicht schützen wir
müssen die Neutralität schützen indem
wir die Landesverteidigung aufrüsten und
wieder aufbauen denn nur eine wehrhafte
Neutralität garantiert auch eine
wehrhafte Demokratie und aufgrund der
Entwicklungen die wir insbesondere in
den letzten wenigen Jahren gesehen haben
in der Nähe auch unser Staatsgrenzen
egal ob es im Nahen Osten ist oder in
der Ukraine befinden wir uns in einer
gänzlich neuen Realität in einer
gänzlich neuen Realität insbesondere für
junge Heranwachsende Menschen eine
Realität die vor wenigen Jahren nur kaum
jemand für möglich gehalten hat eine
Realität in der wir den Fokus wieder auf
die militärische Landesverteidigung
legen müssen und das garantiert unsere
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tanner
gemeinsam mit ihrem Team sehr sehr
eindrucksvoll und das tut sie
abschließend möchte nur einen Appell
sowohl an die Zivildiener als auch an
die grundwertdiener richten nutzt die
Zeit genauso wie unsere
Verteidigungsministerin gesagt hat dass
man etwas lernt dass man sie etwas
mitnehmen kann dass meine Ausbildung
dort auch abschließt es ist nicht nur
Berufsorientierung die man dort erlebt
sondern es kann eben auch vieles
unerwartetes
ja sich sich tun und dieser Türöffner
wirklich auch wahr gemacht werden das
wünsche ich jedem einzelnen von ihnen
von euch und vielen herzlichen Dank für
eure Arbeit aber natürlich auch in den
unterschiedlichsten Einrichtungen egal
ob beim Bundesheer oder im Zivildienst
danke schön ja herzlichen Dank ich darf
ih Frage suchen zu wen das Mikrofon da
ist Frau Ministerin die 15500
grundwerdiener sind das genug für die
Aufgaben im Bundesheer oder bräucht es
mehr es können niemals genug sein weil
ja die auch die Aufgaben die wir als
österreichisches Bundesheer in der
Vergangenheit zu erledigen hatten und
angesichts der Sicherheit äh Lage ohne
Zweifel die Notwendigkeit
besteht das auszugleichen äh diese
geburtens schwachen Jahrgänge das war ja
auch der Hintergrund warum wir eben den
freiwilligen Grundwehrdienst für Frauen
auch eingeführt haben das heißt wir
müssen auf der einen Seite Werbung
betreiben dass diese Entscheidung und da
hat sich ja etwas verändert in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten für das
österreichische Bundesheer äh ausfällt
und insbesondere diese Zeit auch nutzen
das sechs Monate dass die Entscheidung
danach in eine Richtung geht des
Bundesheer sozusagen auch als
Dienstgeber für die Zukunft zu sehen und
das ist unabdingbar notwendig aber sie
sehen ja das österreichische Bundesheer
hat in der Vergangenheit und das werden
wir auch in Zukunft seine Aufgaben immer
erfüllt nur von der Größenordnung her
sie haben jetzt 200 mehr Frauen bekommen
aber ist das die Größenordnung oder
bräuchten sie 5000 Grundwert inner meh
na ich glaube die Zahl so wie sie jetzt
ist ist eine mit der wir einfach
arbeiten müssen und auskommen müssen das
ist einfach ein ein Faktum aber es
schließt nicht aus dass wir nach neuen
Möglichkeiten auch suchen insbesondere
der Bewerbung auch suchen es hat sich so
vieles verändert die statssekretärin hat
angesprochen
diese diese
die Frage der geistigen
Landesverteidigung worum geht's
eigentlich wenn wir diese diese Zeit Mö
ischen Bundesheer auch zur Verfügung
stellen da haben wir einen Schritt schon
gesetzt indem wir diese in den
Lehrplänen auch wieder untergebracht
haben und da ist natürlich das Ziel dass
wir mehr an grundwertinen auch bekommen
das steht das steht außer das steht
außer
Frage die Frau Ministerin hätte gern
mehr grundwerdinaer das Rote Kreuz hätte
mehr gern mehr Zivildiener da gab's
jetzt auch in den letzten Tagen
Hilferufe dass ich das nicht mehr
ausgehen wird dienst in der Form dann
aufrecht zualten mit Hinblick auf die
gutten schwachen Jahrgänge was ist ihr
Rezept ihre Antwort wie kann man da den
Hilfsorganisationen unter die armifen
wir sind in sehr sehr guten Einvernehmen
und in einer guten Zusammenarbeit mit
den unterschiedlichsten
zivildiensteinrichtungen 15501 an der
Zahl und 40% der Zivildiener leisten wie
gesagt ihren Dienst in den
Rettungsorganisationen ich kenne diese
Kritik die in erster Linie von der
zuständigen Landesrätin aus
Niederösterreich gekommen ist man muss
aber schon auch dazu sagen und das hat
sie vergessen zu sagen dass bei den
einrückterminen April bzw juli diese
erst angelaufen sind bzw erst seit
kurzem laufen also da wird sie gerade
die nächsten Wochen und Monate einiges
tun es ist meist aus ganz pragmatischen
Gründen so dass diese einrücktermine
viel viel schwächer besetzt sind weil
man logisch an eine Ausbildung als
junger Bursch auch anschließen möchte
wenn man die Lehrabschlussprüfung im
Sommer macht wenn man die Matura im
Sommer macht dann sind diese
einrücktermine deutlich beliebter das
Rote Kreuz hat in genau diesen konkreten
Fall der Landesrätin in Niederösterreich
auch widersprochen vielleicht auch hier
die konkreten Zahlen ich habe Österreich
weit von einer Bedarfsdeckung der
Einrichtungen von fast 90% gesprochen
wir haben sie um 2 % steigern können und
in Niederösterreich liegt die
Bedarfsdeckung im vergangenen Jahr bei
92,5% dort war eine Steigerung von 6% zu
vernehmen und es ist auch bereits jetzt
in der Tat so dass gewisse
zivildiensteinrichtungen Priorität haben
bei der Zuweisung und dort zählen auch
die Rettungsorganisationen dazu also
egal ob es beim Roten Kreuz ist egal ob
es beim samaritbund ist bei den
johannittern in diesen
unterschiedlichsten Einrichtungen haben
wir eine sehr sehr gute Zusammenarbeit
über unsere
zivildienstsiceagentur noch kurz ich
habe nicht Niederösterreich kliziert ich
habe vom rotenkreuz in Oberösterreich im
Heimatbundesland wenn Sie wahrscheinlich
auch mitbekommen haben gab's auch große
aufgören vom zuständigen Landesrat
insofern um das sozusagen nicht auf
Niederösterreich zu begrenzen Sie sagen
das wird sie ausgehen und sie planen da
keinerlei
Unterstützungen oder Reformen im in
diesem Rahmen wie gesagt die
Bedarfsdeckung ist in gesamtösterreich
auch gestiegen es liegt an sehr
pragmatischen Gründen warum die
einrücktermine im Frühjahr weniger
beliebt sind aber ich glaube durch eine
gute Bewerbung kann man das auch
garantieren und es werden sich die
nächsten Wochen nachdem das erst
angelaufen ist auch genügend ausreichend
Zivildiener finden werden die Zahlen ne
das ja schon in den vergangenen Jahren
immer wieder auch her und wir arbeiten
sehr sehr eng mit den
zivildiensteinrichtungen zusammen ich
kann nur an jeden appellieren der vor
dieser Entscheidung steht welche
Einrichtung man wählt dass man sie
frühzeitig informiert frühzeitig auch um
eine Stelle umschaut und direkt bei der
Zivildienst Einrichtung auch
bewirbt fr Ministerin könnten sie noch
ein paar nähere Details nennen was sind
die häufigsten Gründe für die
Untauglichkeit der whpflichtigen jungen
Männer und Frau Staatssekretärin
es gibt ja seit 1 September diese
Möglichkeit der Grundausbildung Pflege
haben sie da Zahlen wie viele sich da
bisher dafür entschieden
haben das was wir wir sehen hat sich die
die letzten Jahre über schon
herausgestellt das hat eben zu tun mit
äh einer nicht vorhandenen
entsprechenden körperlichen Fitness die
insbesondere
Übergewicht betrifft es ist für uns
herausfordernd das dann aufzuholen was
über über Jahre und von klein auf
versäumt worden ist das was wir auch
gesehen haben dass da die Belastungen im
psychischen Bereich durchaus zugenommen
haben das sind wie gesagt die
vorwiegenden Dinge wenn wir von der
Anzahl so wie der Herr daser
richtigerweise auch nachgefragt hat der
Grundwert und dem dem Bemühen hier mehr
zu bekommen trotz der Geburts schwachen
Jahrgänge sprechen dann war schon diese
Einführung der teiltauglichkeit wichtig
ich habe die Zahlen auch genannt dieser
639 000 da noch einmal der Hinweis also
da von einem Etikettenschwindel zu
sprechen wie es die die landesrätinin in
Niederösterreich gemacht hat entspricht
schlichtweg nicht nicht den Fakten weil
das waren eben 639 die wir dazu bekommen
haben jeder einzelne grundwerdiener bzw
Zivildiener bei uns heißt das ein mehr
auch an an Sicherheit aber das wird eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe werden
hier im Gesundheitsbereich auch
Maßnahmen zu setzen erste sind ja schon
erfolgt die im in den Volksschulen
beginnen mit zusätzlichen
Bewegungseinheiten das wird man ohne
Zweifel auch mehr machen müssen bei
allen auch Fragen der der der
teiltaaglichkeit muss man eines auch
sagen ein Mindestmaß ein Mindestmaß an
körperlichen und geistigen Fähigkeit
muss eben vorhanden sein um des Tages
auch eine Waffe betätigen zu können das
ist ja verfassungsrechtlich auch eine
eine Notwendigkeit die so vorgesehen ist
im Gesetz wenn ich hier nur gleich auch
anschließen darf wir haben im Sommer den
achten Bericht zur Lage der Jugend
präsentiert und dort ist das Thema
Nummer ein bei jungen Menschen
Gesundheit und damit leistet das
österreichische Bundesheer mit den
stellungsstraßen ja auch einen
wesentlichen Beitrag dazu dass junge
Menschen auch Vorsorge treffen können an
Faktencheck sozusagen über die eigene
Gesundheit auch haben und dass dem auch
mehr Priorität eingeräumt wird ich hoffe
das sieht man dann auch an den Zahlen in
den nächsten Jahren das Gesundheit
einfach seit der
coronaapandemie sowohl körperlich als
auch psychisch ein eines der Top Themen
für junge Menschen insgesamt ist und ich
muss auch sagen es braucht ein
Mindestmaß an körperlicher Eignung an
psychischer Eignung es wird sehr sehr
sorgfältig und gewissenhaft bei der
Stellung die whrfähigkeit auch geprüft
und der Zivildienst ist der werr
Ersatzdienst also auch wir zielen hier
logischerweise auf das ab aber wer
ernsthafte psychische Probleme hat den
möchte weder mit einer Waffe in der Hand
nur am Bett meiner Oma als Pfleger sehen
am Ende des Tages da bin ich auch bei
der Grundausbildung pflege ich bin sehr
sehr stolz darauf dass wir diese
Grundausbildung auf den Weg gebracht
haben und damit neben der
sanitäterprüfung auch einen Baustein
sozusagen einer Ausbildung in die neu
Monate Zivildienst bringen am 1
September hat der Nationalratsbeschluss
sozusagen seine Wirkung erfasst und und
damit ist auch der statschuss für die
Bundesländer gefallen dass das
sogenannte UBV Modul für Zivildiener
geöffnet wird UBV Unterstützung in der
Basisversorgung das ist der Beginn einer
jeden Pflegeausbildung in Österreich und
dieses Modul im Rahmen von 140
in Rahmen von 100 Theorieeinheiten und
40 Praxiseinheiten kann ab sofort dann
auch in den Pflegeschulen angenommen
werden wir sind hier ein Beginn wie
gesagt die Bundesländer haben jetzt die
nötigen rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen
dafür und und ich bin zuversichtlich
dass wir in einigen Monaten auch die
ersten zivileder haben die diese
Grundausbildung abgeschlossen haben es
wird für fast 50% der Zivildiener
möglich sein weil fast 50% der
Zivildiener in Einrichtungen im
Sozialbereich in der in der Behinderten
Hilfe beispielsweise auch Arbeiten in
der Altenpflege auch arbeiten und
ich denke dass es ein eine gute
Möglichkeit ist wo einfach noch ne9
Monaten Zivildienst auch etwas bleibt wo
er eine Ausbildung anschließen kann in
genau diesem Bereich wo mir das ubvmul
auch angerechnet wird und wenn ich
beispielsweise nach dem Zivildienst eine
pflegelehre statte und im Zivildienst
das UBV Modul gemacht hab dann werden
wir sogar sech Monate des Zivildienst
angerechnet wie viele haben sich bisher
gemeldet das lauft wie gesagt jetzt in
den Bundesländern an mit september haben
die Bundesländer diesen statschuss
bekommen die Pflegeschulen dafür zu
rüsten dass Zivildiener jetzt auch diese
Ausbildung starten können wir werden in
den nächsten Monaten denke ich äh ja von
äh die ersten Zivildiener haben die
diese Ausbildung auch bereits
abgeschlossen haben gibt weitere
Fragen wenn nicht dann s ich herzlichen
Dank für kommen und die press danke
schön danke
schön